can you confirm that report there's been
a recent meeting between
stephen or yourself and urban meyer
that's not correct i can i can confirm
that it is absolutely not correct
we have not met with any coach
specifically
i don't want to imply that we wouldn't
in a way that would diminish
the credibility of other sort of in this
case a player or somebody you're asking
about normally when somebody says are
you interested in such and such you said
i have not the implication is you're not
interested that shouldn't be uh
brought
forward either the facts are we just
have not talked to any coach potential
coach in the nfl
jerry jones back on 105.3 the fan in
dallas on tuesday apparently
did not utter any words that got him
bleeped or otherwise cut like he was on
friday when he said a word that he
shouldn't have said multiple times we
can relate to that here i guess although
we have yet to be bleeped or cut that we
know of jerry jones talking about urban
meyer and look there was a report from
nfl media last week that they've spoken
to urban meyer the question that jerry
addressed yesterday was whether they met
with urban meyer there's a difference
there you can speak with a guy exactly
and not meet with a guy right and and he
said that's not correct he didn't like
say like no we haven't talked to him or
you know met with them you're right
that's where i i was tuned in there too
sorry go ahead
this is the time of year where owners
line up the candidates where they
determine the universe of potential
coaches and the candidates know that as
well this is when the decisions are made
even though they aren't officially made
until january as a practical matter
they're made now why do you think all of
a sudden mike mccarthy is emerging
they've got this long feature on nfl
network about all the work that he's
doing he's trying to get his name back
into circulation and frankly i haven't
heard his name much in circulation so
he's trying to force it in that's
exactly what is happening now and guys
hey you think you think jerry jones is
thinking about mike mccarthy i don't
know but
this is what's happening the teams are
looking the candidates are making sure
everybody knows they're out there and
there's a lot of stuff that's happening
behind the scenes so i think it would be
foolish if jerry jones if he's
interested in urban meyer to not at
least have the conversation now so they
know whether or not he's a viable
candidate when january rolls around yeah
well i agreed i mean listen i do think
urban meyer uh certainly could could be
successful in the nfl and with the
dallas cowboys uh uh you know and two
you know i believe jane slater in her
reports on that jane slater's in the
know in the nfl she knows people i i get
it so i don't think she just threw that
out there now yeah probably didn't meet
with them but i bet you uh where she
reported that they've talked or
something like that i would bet that's
very true that at least some preliminary
conversations have gone on to your point
you know urban meyer
is the type of coach i do think the
dallas cowboys need um they need a guy
that can go in there and kind of button
everything up you know the team the
talent that's all there listen i don't
think mike mccarthy's that bad of an
idea there either you know my thoughts
with mike mccarthy i like everything
about him except the play caller you
know so if he kept kellen moore and then
was the head coach that would work too
but uh i do think that i don't think
like the young guy
a lincoln riley or a kellen moore type
or anything like that is the right fit
for this dallas cowboy football team one
i think they would be a little
overwhelmed by the jones family and
having to deal with them on a daily
basis and just like having to take those
orders two
this is a team that's ready to win now
this is not like the arizona cardinals
who are building something and then they
can hire a cliff kingsbury they are in
their super bowl window as we speak they
are as talented as any team in football
and therefore they need a guy who
seasoned and really understands the big
picture and how to run and manage an nfl
football team
two things first of all i think the guy
that jerry jones wants is sean payton
yeah probably just be just because
payton got an extension earlier this
year look would it be crazy to think
that the extension was leaked and
reported and announced and whatever in
order to take off the table a full
season of speculation that sean payton
will be the next coach of the cowboys
and if sean payton hadn't had that
extension
signed announced whatever
every comment about jason garrett likely
being out would be followed by maybe
sean payton will be in that hasn't
happened yet yes that and and it's so
it's smart and nobody's ever accused
sean payton of not being smart so uh i i
think jerry still wants sean payton that
is at the top of his wish list and we'll
see if it goes in that direction one
thing about mccarthy yeah don't you
think the fact that the packers are ten
and three and number two right now in
the nfc without mccarthy yes hurts
mccarthy's chance uh a hundred percent i
do i'm glad you brought that up because
i that that that is worthy uh you're
right uh it does not look good on mike
mccarthy the fact that yeah he got fired
uh before the season ended with a
horrible loss to the arizona cardinals
who were one of the worst teams in
football after actually the worst
football team and uh now that team is
thriving yeah just it's not a good look
on mike but i still think mike's a hell
of a head coach i just like i said i
don't like his play calling when he's
doing that
right and that would be the last guy
that jerry jones would want to hire
because that's exactly the problem with
jason garrett yeah right right
right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports